mais mes mes chers
collègues je je suis ravi d'accueillir
ce matin Frédéric del l'orme président
de rail logistique Europe dans le cadre
du cycle d'audition sur le fret
ferroviaire frê ferroviaire que nous
avions cycle d'audition et fra
ferroviaire que nous avions initié en
juillet dernier après l'audition de
Raphaël
d'outrebande président de l'Alliance fr
ferroviaire français du futur 4F il
était en effet incontournable d'attendre
d'entendre l'un des principaux acteurs
du transport ferroviaire de marchandises
à savoir rail logistique Europe qui
réunit cinq filiales au premier rang
desquel Fret SNCF et pour cause comme
vous le savez l'avenir du Fret SNCF
reste pour l'heur incertain je rappelle
que la Commission européenne a ouvert en
janvier dernier une procédure formel sur
les conditions de financement du frait
SNCF elle considère en effet que les
aides versées entre 2007 et 2019 par la
maison mère SNCF à son activité de frite
alors ouvertees à la concurrence n'ont
pas été conduites dans le respect des
règles européennes les montants
concernés s'élèvent environ à 5
milliards d'euros dans ce contexte une
issue défavorable de la procédure
impliquerait pour Fret SNCF de
rembourser ces 5 milliards d'euros ce
qui de fait conduirait à sa liquidation
et constituerait sans doute un coût
fatal porté au fretes ferroviaires en
France c'est pourquoi les autorités
françaises privilégient un plan de
discontinuité pour reprendre
l'appellation contrôlée couramment
utilisée aujourd'hui qui a vocation à ce
que la Commission constate l'existence
d'une discontinuité économique entre
Fret SNCF et la structure qui lui
succéderait et de sorte éteindre le
risque de rembours
des 5 milliards d'euros aussi
pourriez-vous monsieur de l'Orme nous
présenter l'état d'avancement concernant
l'issue qui sera retenue pour Fr SNCF et
les conditions fixées par un tel plan de
discontinuité la remise sur le marché de
certaines parties de l'activité et
l'ouverture du capital à des
actionnaires minoritaires en particulier
ne risqu-ell pas de déstabiliser
durablement l'entreprise et plus
généralement le secteur du fr froviaire
pourriez-vous également nous préciser
comment vous vous préparez aux
évolutions à venir notamment ce qui
concerne les employés de fret SNCF
au-delà du cas particulier de fret SNCF
avez-vous connaissance d'autres États
concernés par une procédure analogue
faut-il voir un risque pour le la
dynamique du fret ferroviaire je viens
j'en viens à présent à la situation plus
globale du transport ferroviaire de
marchandise qui semble il commencer à
retrouver une trajectoire trajectoire
positive entre 2020 et
2022 monsieur
d'outrebante nous a toutefois indiqué
que cette tendance avait récemment connu
une inflexion en raison notamment de la
hausse des prix de l'énergie et des
conséquences des grèves qu'en est-il
s'agissant de frit SNCF et plus
globalement du groupe
rle quels sont les segments d'activité
les plus en difficulté et à l'inverse ce
qui tir leur épingle du jeu en aût quel
bilan tirez-vous du plan de relance et
du prolongement des aides à
l'exploitation d'après vous les moyens
mobilisés sont-ils de nature à permettre
aux fraites ferroviaire de doubler sa
part modale dans le transport de
marchandises d'ici à 2030 comme le
prévoit l'article 131 de la loi climat
et résilience de
2021 sans plus tarder je vous cède la
parole pour un propos liminminire d'une
dizaine de minutes avant de le laisser à
mes collègues euh a commencé par
philippe Tabarot rapporteur budgétaire
pour avis sur les crédits àouer au
transport ferroviaire vous posez leurs
question vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs je suis d'abord heureux de
pouvoir revenir discuter de de du
développement du frê de ferroviaire avec
vous ici moah je commencerai par le
positif euh si on fait un flashback
2122 ce sont des années à marquer d'une
pierre blanche parce que la part de
marché du fra de ferroviaire a
augmenté c'était pas arrivé depuis 30
ans une infection assez significative un
point et demi quand on est à 9 % et
qu'on vise 18 % en un an c'est c'est
significatif les résultats économiques
de nos entreprise de rle r Logistics
Europe qui en dehors de fret SNCF a
d'autres filiales et le numéro 1 en
France avec à peu près 2 tiers de
l'activité du fret mais aussi numéro 2
en Europe se sont amélioré fr CCF là
aussi d'un point de vue historique sur
2122 a généré un un ébit d' positif
alors c'est pas encore suffisant pour
financer les investissements durables
mais en tout cas c'était quelque chose
qu'on a qualifié d'historique he sur 212
et bah Ray Logistics Europe qui est
quand même le l'acteur logistique de Fra
ferroviaire de la France en Europe le
plus grand le plus le plus présent
puisqu'on est numéro 2 derrière la Dutch
ban bah j'ai regardé un petit peu les
trajectoires de ratio débit sur chi
d'affair des grands opérateurs de taille
équivalente desb
cargo RCG les Autrichiens l'INAS les
Belges les Suisses aussi quand dans la
même période malheureusement et c'est
pas une bonne nouvelle pour le secteur
une grande partie de ces opérateurs ont
vu leur taux débit sur chif d'affaires
se dégrader nous nous avons eu la plus
belle progression d'Europe donc donc
voilà vous m'auriez fait venir en 22
vous m'riez vu qu'avec le sourire
malheureusementites venir en 23 et donc
là j'ai enchaîné bah les facteurs de
succès il y en avait trois sur cette
période là c'était un une vraie
politique publique en faveur du fraet
ferroviaire al on pourra discuter de
savoir si elle est suffisante sielle
peut encore être améliorée pour viser le
doublement la loi climat et résilience
qui fixait des objectifs et qui a été
suivi des
faits le deuxème c'est qu'on a fait
notre job on a amélioré notre
performance intrinsèque et puis la
troisème et c'est pas ligable il y a eu
la paix sociale voilà quand on a ces
trois conditions une vraie politique
publique qui réquilibre entre le rail et
la route euh et qui donne des
perspective clair euh que nous on fait
notre job et qu'on a la paix sociale ça
marche voilà donc il y a pas de fatalité
à ce que le fret ne se développe pas
2023 bah c'est une autre année euh des
facteurs exogènes assez considérabl les
grèves de de de retraite euh qui étaient
pas d'ailleurs forcément des grèves de
de Frot SNCF hein c'était plutôt l'accès
au réseau qui nous a posé problème euh
ont eu un impact sur le chit d'affair de
rail Logistics Europe de 90 millions
d'euros donc plus de la moitié pour Frat
SNCF euh sur un chi d'affair d'un
milliard en France puisquon fait un
milliard 7 en Europe mais en France 1
milliard les 90 millions d'euros c'est
évidemment en France pour
l'essentiel un choc énergétique qui a
continué alors que en 2022 il y avait un
soutien au secteur sur l'énergie en 2023
on l'a pas vu alors que dans le même
temps bah il y a eu quand même une
modération du prix du gasoil pour les
routiers on voit le prix du GNR
augmenter et le coût de l'énergie
électrique augmenté et puis il y a eu
l'accident de la Morienne qui dont on
sait maintenant que probablement on
pourra plus aller en Italie avant un an
au moins euh pour Don un ordre de
grandeur pour nous c'est 20 million
d'euros de chit d'affair là aussi en
année pleine donc c'est quand même trois
mauvaise nouvelle
exogène qui impacte sur not chit d'ffair
d'un milliard de r en France notre
rentabilité de plus de une baisse de 10
% il y a pas beaucoup de secteurs qui
peuvent se permettre d'absorber ça et en
plus on est une entreprise à coup fixe
voilà donc alors lasbnos list
conséquence sans doute de de la crise
ukrainienne et et de l'économie générale
les électrointensifs que sont la
sidérurgie ou la chimie par exemple on
voit leur volume en ce moment baisser en
matière de transport de l'ordre de 20 %
et donc on a une baisse des volumes une
baisse des volumes lié à l'économie bon
ça c'est notre métier nous adapter à
l'économie mais ça se cumule avec ce que
j'ai dit avant et puis 2023 vous l'avez
dit monsieur le Président euh sanction
de la Commission
européenne pour le passé 2007-209 alors
qu'on était revenu à au moins au petit
équilibre sur Fret SNCF en 212
discontinuité à mettre en œuvre ça veut
dire sans putter d'un bras hein
abandonner les trafics de train entier
régulier ce qui représente 20 % du chif
d'affaires de frit SNCF ça fait beaucoup
voilà pour le dirigeant que je suis je
vous cache pas ça fait beaucoup
alors je reviendrai sur la discontinuité
plus en détail avec vos questions
évidemment il y a
l'enquête de la commission parlementaire
où pendant 1 heure et3 j'aiétaé
auditionné bon clairement c'est un choc
parce que ça arrive à un moment où pour
nous la discontinuité elle intervient
alors qu'on était revenu au petit
équilibre alors qu'il a plus de plignant
et alors qu'il y a une demande de plan
de relance notamment en France et un grd
deal en Europe bon la commission dans
son droit au sens propre du terme
puisque le droit de la concurrence
s'applique à tous on s'est battu sur le
terrain du droit mais sur le fait que
ces aides étaient illégal parce que
fléché sur fret à cause d'un déficit
chronique bah on a perdu sur le terrain
du droit de la concurrence puisque ils
ont décidé d'ouvrir la procédure après
plusieurs années de discussion informell
au au 18 janvier 2023 alors avec l'État
on s'est fixé quatre lignes rouges il
fallait absolument que à la fin benah il
y ait pas rembourser les 5 milliards
sinon Fret SNCF premier opérateur de
France de fret ferroviaire disparaît et
c'est on avait regardé ça quand même
convaincu la commission c'est il
disparaît ça peut conduire jusqu'à 1
million de camions en plus sur les
routes et le bilan carbone sera
absolument catastrophique parce que fret
est quand même le premier opérateur en
concurrence avec la route notamment sur
le wagon isolé donc on s'est fixé
plusieurs objectifs pas de report modal
inversé une entreprise qui Rena tout ça
sous forme d'une discontinuité
économique qui va changer de nom au 1er
janvier 2025 et perd 20 % de son chif
d'affair qui doit être viable
économiquement évidemment vis-à-vis des
salariés pas de licenciement protéger
les salariés pour qu'on puisse les le
retrouver un emploi dans dans
l'entreprise grâce à la solidarité
groupe alors à fret ou ailleurs et puis
pas de privatisation puisque le but
c'est d'ouvrir le capital à un
minoritaire mais qui aura un contrôle
conjoint sur sur
l'entreprise bon le bilan de tout ça
c'est que la sol solution qui est déjà
en train d'être mise en œuvre puisqueau
1er janvier 2024 on abandonne une partie
de no trafic pour ite ensuite faire
créer une nouvelle entreprise qui ne
sera pas redevable des 5 milliards de
dettes cette solution est viable parce
que dans le même temps il y a un coût
économique c'est vrai mais on perd des
trafics contributifs donc il y a un coût
économique mais la politique de soutien
au plan de relance du frais de
ferrovière en France qui va amené une
augmentation de 30 millions d'euros d'ê
supplémentaire par rapport au 170
millions d'euros du plan de relance à
partir de 2025 et jusqu'en 2030 a dit
Clément ba nous permet quand je fais le
quand on fait le bilan entre ce qu'on
perd et ce qu'on gagne avoir finalement
une trajectoire équivalente à celle qu'
aurait été frit SNCF même si
l'entreprise est réduite il y a un seul
point qui me gêne c'est qu'en 2024
euh bah ces aides sont pas mises en
place alors qu'on discontinue dès le 1er
janvier 2024 et donc ce que je dis pour
2025 vaut pas en 2024 et aujourd'hui le
budget que je présente d'ailleurs cet
après-midi à mon président est un budget
négatif sur FR SNCF ce qui est pas une
bonne nouvelle parce que ça donne pas
envie forcément au marché de
s'intéresser à nous pour un investisseur
qui doit
venir rentrer au capital et puis je
trouve c'est pas un mauvais un bon
signal donné au secteur parce que on
traverse une crise raphaë d'outrebante
l'a souligné grève énergie Morienne et
cetera où l'accompagnement sur ce choc
sur 23 et 24 serait le bienvenu pour l'
du secteur voilà moi vu de frit SNCF
évidemment les aides au vagon isolés
contribuent à l'économie générale de la
nouvelle société qui naîra au 1er
janvier 2025 mais n'empêche que la
discontinuité dès le 1er janvier 2024 et
qu'elle a un coût et que les 30 million
d'euros supplémentaires serait bienvenu
al je sais qu'il y a un amendement qui a
été proposé qui est le bienvenu on le
soutient
totalement parce que je pense que dans
cette période difficile ce sera un
signal fort donné à notre secteur
notamment parce qu'on en 2023 il y a eu
tout ce que j'ai cité qui nous a
beaucoup
affecté voilà alors ceci étant 2021 22
formidable 23 euh on cumule tous les
toutes les difficultés ça remet pas en
cause de mon point de vue la tendance
voilà et j'ai écouté avec beaucoup
d'attention l'audition de Madame bertelo
de la FNTR qui est pour le le transfert
modal en disant faut pas paiser la route
et le rail le temps de la décarbonation
va être très long elle dit que le coûp
d'un tracteur électrique pour la route
c'est trois fois plus cher aujourd'hui
qu'un
qu'un tracteur diesel que on sait pas
trop entre l'hydrogène et l'énergie
électrique à clar tout ça va se déployer
de toute façon il y aura un coût alors
peut-être qu'il peut être financé
supporté mais dans quelle proportion et
nous je rappelle on est tout de suite
disponible donc on n' pas de doute que
la tendance des chargeurs c'est de
demander plus de rail et ils l'ont
exprimé à nouveau donc moi j'ai pas de
doute sur la tendance hein voilà on
traverse une passe difficile 2324 vont
deux années difficiles mais les
conditions sont là pour augmenter la
part de marché du est-ce qu'on fera le
doublement parce que c'était votre
question alors j'ai vu une présentation
d'Antoine payon à France logistique qui
dit qui parler plus de 18 % de part de
marché en 2030 et 15 % c'est ce qui me
paraît réaliste voilà je veux pas vous
mentir c'est ce qui me paraît réaliste
d'ailleurs notre trajectoire de de pour
rle et pour fret est plutôt sur cet
ordre de grandeur moi quand je présente
mes mes plans stratégiques à 10 ans en
2030 on est plutôt sur le 14 15 % de par
de marché mais enfin ce serait déjà une
dynamique formidable que d'être passé de
9 % dans un contexte en plus économique
compliqué à 15 % en 2030 et on atteindra
forcément les 18 % de 3 ans après voilà
ce que je pense du point de vue de la
réalité de l'atteinte ou non du fouie de
Al vous me dit vous me direz c'est en
écart avec la loi mais après c'est les
chargeurs qui qui décident dans un
contexte économique qu'est-ce qu'il est
qu'est-ce qui nous manque pour aller
plus loin ou même sécuriser cette
trajectoire ben je vais plutôt dire les
deux thèmes que j'ai en tête et plutôt
vous laisser ensuite venir à travers les
questions et y répondre la première
c'est réseau réseau réseau mon collègue
de Matthieu chabanal a faire face à une
demande croissante de régénération bonne
nouvelle ces crédits vont être augmentés
donc beaucoup de travaux sur le réseau
une demande croissante de développement
des voyageurs notamment avec les
services de RER métropolitain et un
objectif de X 2 bah il faut faut que
l'équation puisse être résolue et je
vous cache pas que je le répète souvent
il il y a une inquiétude de notre part
sur la visibilité qu'on peut avoir sur
des parties du réseau qui peut être
totalement saturé à l'horizon 3 4 an et
où donc avant 2030 une partie des
trafics notamment du transport combiné
pourrait pas s'écouler simplement parce
qu'on n' pas accès aux voix voilà
globalement le réseau n'est pas saturé
en moyenne mais il y a des endroits
l'île-de
France la région haut--fance autour de
l'île le nœud Lyonnais j'étais en région
Grand Est bah de tout la Dijon on sait
que il va y avoir avir des problèmes le
sillon moséan par exemple la plaine
d'Alsace enfin tout ça c'est des
endroits on sait que ça va être saturé
mais on sait pas quand est- ce qu'il
faut faire pour le faire donc il manque
une rubrique désaturation investissement
de désaturation pour que réseau puisse
faire face à l'ensemble des besoins et
évidemment on voudrait pas être la
variable d'ajustement deuxème sujet
c'est décision de
qualité je vais demain à la RT et j'ai
vu que la RT s'est exprimé en faveur des
accords cadres à 5 à 10 ans permettant
de garantir en con et réalisation des
sons de qualité alors pour le fret on
les demande beaucoup pour le transport
combiné parce qu'il est extrêmement
sensible à la performances des sillons
et puis il y avait dans le plan de
relance 210 million d'euros qui avait
été prévu sur 3 ans pour financer des
surcoups de travaux qui permettent de
libérer des sillons de qualité parce que
la nuit il y a un conflit entre les
travaux et les sillons notamment du
combiné et ça permettait et ça a permis
même un réseau de libérer des sillons
pour le fret sauf que que cette mesure
elle s'arrête en 2024 donc on pose la
question et la suite parce que si on se
met à la place de réseau ils ont une
équation difficile à résoudre mais faire
les travaux sur une voie puis une voie
plutôt de fermer les voies les deux
voies en même temps c'est pas le même
cût voilà et donc accompagner réseau
pour qu'il
puisse financer des sillons fret c'est
important et comme l'a dit sans doute
raphaë doutband nous aimerions avoir la
visibilité sur les 4 milliards d'
d'investissement en terme de
programmation et nous appelons avec 4 F
de nos vux une BO de programmation
invvestissement voilà j'ai par ailleurs
des mesures que j'ai indiqué à
l'Assemblée nationale puis je vais
m'arrêter là je je vous les préciserai
après qu'on pourrait prendre je dirais
périphérique un plan de relance que nous
considérons comme bon hein franchement 4
milliards 2 sur pour le seul fret c'est
bien les 200 millions d'euros c'est très
bien c'est ce qu'on demandait 4 F donc
on va pas se plaindre d'ici 2030 ça se
met en place en 2025 on a le sujet 2024
qui pose question mais on pourrait
prendre d'autres mesures incitatives et
notamment dans la complémentarité
rouraille pour pas opposer les deux
modes que je pourrais vous détailler
dans le cadre de nos échanges mais que
j'ai indiqué aussi à l'Assemblée
nationale lors de mon audition et on
pourra vous remet d'ailleurs une petite
note qui qui reprend ses propositions et
qui pourrait booster le plan de relance
pour le sécuriser voilà mon appréciation
de la situation monsie le président
merci monsieur le Président alors je
vais donner la parole à Stéphane
[Musique]
demil puis après merci beaucoup monsieur
le Président juste une petite question
complémentaire à à à vos propos
lorsqu'on observe les les politiques de
soutien à l'activité de de de frait de
ferroviaire à l'étranger on remarque
parfois on est un petit peu à la traain
dans dans notre pays parce que les les
subventions publiques sont souvent plus
élevées dans des pays voisin je pense en
particulier à l'Allemagne à l'Autriche
ou à la Suisse et même à nos voisins
belges donc voilà pensez-vous que que
que la politique du développement du du
fret en France a trop longtemps souffert
d'un d'un d'une absence de stratégie
globale et et notamment d'un
accompagnement de la part de
l'État monsieur Weber et après monsieur
gilet
oui merci monsieur le Président en tout
cas de cette de cette présentation vous
l'avez dit c'est un petit peu d'ailleurs
ce qui me surprend c'est queon a
vraiment l'impression qu'il y a pas de
stratégie claire qui est définie vous
avez parler vous avez évoqué des des
secteurs vous en avez cité quelques-uns
dont un qui me concerne qui est celui du
sonillon mosellan avec des inquiétudes
quant à l'avenir de saturation et
cetera mais finalement quand on vous
entend on sent qu'il y a une prise de
conscience de la
situation on voit que effectivement il y
a pas de quoi être rassuré sur lesps de
marché sur l'évolution et avec des des
problèmes qui sont des problèmes
conjoncturels certes mais finalement
aussi structurels liés à
l'infrastructure à la concurrence
peut-être avec le trafic voyageur mais
surtout quand comment et quelle
anticipation et quel moyens on met en
œuvre pour essayer d'accompagner un
développement potentiel du FR
ferroviaire on y on n pas de de
proposition de solution donc je suis
très étonné finalement alors je sais que
David Valence est aussi engagé sur le
sur le sujet député des des vuges je
crois qu'il mne une commission d'enquête
ou sur ces questions là mais en tout cas
je suis assez inquiet et on a vraiment
le sentiment que c'est non seulement le
parent pauvre mais peut-être même le
parent oublié finalement de la politique
française en terme de frite et de
ferroviaire
merci Monsieur le le président alors
effectivement pour aller à la suite de
de l'intervention de de mon collègue on
a beaucoup de difficultés parce que on a
le sentiment de pas disposer d'un
document mître stratégique prospectif
qui nous permettrait d'avoir des lignes
de visibilité sur l'ensemble des
territoires et et c'est un vrai souci
c'est un vrai souci que parce que face à
la complexité du sujet c'est très
délicat d'arriver à se positionner sans
avoir des lignes de priorité stratégique
et qui impactent effectivement les
territoires mais avec forcément en terme
de logistique une forme de
complémentarité et d'intermodalité aussi
à trouver pour
optimiser d'une manière générale les les
flux donc on a une vraie difficulté à
l'heure actuelle donc je vraiment je
voudrais vous sensibiliser et et de fait
donc au niveau des stradet sur le
positionnement aussi des régions donc
dans l'interaction des acteurs on a du
mal à à à imaginer quelles sont
réellement les priorités et le champ du
possible
parce que prenons l'exemple de la région
nouvelleaquitaine tant qu'on narrivera
pas à franchir correctement la frontière
espagnole ça va être compliqué ça va
être très compliqué et c'est c'est pas
encore pour demain si j'ai bien compris
donc où sont véritablement les les
priorités des grands flux logistiques en
France ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point sur les logistiques
intermédiaires et les déplacement
intermédiaire j'ai bien entendu ce que
vous disiez sur la décarbonation de la
flotte néanmoins néanmoins on constate
une progression significative
aujourd'hui mais sur des transports de
moyenne distance c'està-dire qui
commence à y avoir effectivement un
effet de
développement de sur la décarbonation du
transport sur la moyenne distance on va
dire inférieure à 400 km bon ok mais ça
a un impact quand même c'est un impact
qui n'est pas forcément négligeable en
terme de prospective et là également
comment mesure-t-on cet impact et on
parle bien en
2023 donc les gaps et les sauts
technologiques que l'on va pouvoir
constater dans les années à venir vont
sans doute déplacer cette barre des 400
pour aller un peu plus loin donc il y
aura un impact de toute manière et on
voit bien que sur les ruptures de
charges puisque c'est le principal souci
aujourd'hui du développement entre
autres par rapport à l'exposé que vous
avez pu avoir sur lequel je suis tout à
fait d'accord il y a pas de souci mais
quand même il y a il y a quand même et
donc on a une grande difficulté en terme
de prospective aujourd'hui pour pouvoir
se positionner
et et je pense que pour l'appropriation
politique et la manière dont on on peut
effectivement se positionner c'est un un
grave défaut alors vous avez évoqué des
notes à l'Assemblée nationale alors oui
envoyz les n assez rapidement essayez de
les envoyer en parallèle ça nous fera
gagner du
temps proposer de répondre et puis après
je vais donner en premier la parole à
philippe Tabarot et je m'en excuse déjà
auprès du rapporteurir envie de lui
donner la parole juste après votre
propos
liminire
alors sur les pays voisins on a quand
même beaucoup rattrapé notre retard avec
le plan de relance parce que je j'ai
moi-même présenté à Jean Castex quand il
était premier ministre avec Jean-Pierre
farandou une courbe qui montrait la
répartition de la part de marché dans
chaque pays européen par rapport à la
politique publique de soutien au fra de
ferroviaire et on était dernier de la
classe à la fois en part de marché en
soutien avec
l'Espagne à peu près milieu de la courbe
il y avait l'Allemagne est très haut
devant euh la Suisse et l'Autriche alors
il y a pas on peut pas dire qu'il y a
une relation mathématique entre la
politique publique et et puis le volume
parce qu'il y a d'autres facteurs qui
jouent hein il y a la performance des
opérateurs il y a le choix des chargeurs
voilà mais quand même c'était frappant
et donc bah on a corrigé ça alors il y a
des pays ceux qui sont le plus haut
comme la Suisse ils font à la fois la
taxe de la route et l'aide au secteur
ferroviaire ils font les deux bon nous
on a choisi desdes ferroviairees est-ce
que la route paye le coût des
externalités négatives non en France non
donc la question de l'application de de
l'eurovignette la question des Ets la
question la titicpe voilà B t ces sujets
qui qui qui sont latant bon on voit bien
qu'en France il y a pas une volonté
forcément d'ê accé la route nous nous on
demande si c'est pas le cas qu'on aide
le secteur vertueux au bon niveau le
niveau qu'on a aujourd'hui d'aide en
exploitation de 200 millions d'euros par
an et le niveau d'investissement qu'on a
demandé c'est ce que KF a demandé donc
franchement c'est correct on est revenu
dans dans la dans dans la moyenne du
pleloton hein on pour aller plus loin si
en plus la route finançait une partie de
notre de notre développement voilà mais
pour revenir sur la justement la route
moi je les oppose pas
nécessairement je respecte les
politiques publiques qui disent il y a
pas de volonté d'appliquer l'équivalent
deécotaxe même si j'ai vu que certaines
régions pratiquent comme le Grand Est
parce que tout simplement les pays
voisins le font et sinon tous les
camions il passent chez eux donc voilà
moi je vais pas commenter ça je dis
juste que la route on peut l'aider aussi
pour favoriser le ferroviaire parce que
sur le transport combiné un camion qui
fait 400 km il fait forcément 200 km
avec de l'autonomie il est déjà vert
s'il vient au rail à une gare de
marchandise ou s'il vient à une
plateforme combinée amené de la
marchandise pour faire la longue
distance par le ferroviaire il est
vertueux mais ils ont aucune aide ces
gens-là les routiers français qui font
ça finalement dans la politique générale
il y a pas d'avantage à faire ça donc
quelqu'un qui fait du camion de bout en
bout avec un smirmort classique qui doit
changer de logistique passer avec un un
camion avec un plateau sur lequel on met
une caisse mobile ou qui fait l'effort
d'organiser le roulement de ses
conducteurs pour dans les territoire
aller chercher les marchandises à à une
gare pour faire du de la longue distance
par le rail il y a pas d'avantage al ça
fait partie d'ailleurs des des
proposition que nous avons fait ça ve
dire c'est c'est routiers vertueux
quelque part pour les aider alors ça
peut prendre différentes formes ça nous
on a on on a lancer l'idée mais il faut
en discuter avec les routiers eux-mêmes
que il peut avoir des incitations
fiscales par exemple sur l'impôt sur les
sociétés qu'ils ai quelque chose qui
leur soit favorable ça développerait des
emplois en France et j'ai entendu madame
Bertelot dire mais en fait faire du
faire du transport intermodal Raay rout
bah ça limiterait ce qu'on a observé
depuis 30 ans c'està-dire le déferlement
des camions étrangers lituaniens
polonais espagnol qui finalement ne
payent pas leurs externalités négatives
en France et ne font que du transit
parce que ça passerait sur le rail ce
serait des emplois en France et puis le
la collecte et la distribution par la
route développerit des emplois routiers
en France donc il y a quelque chose là
qui manque me semble-t-il dans la
connexion rail route et le rail de ce
point de vue là nous on n pas peur de la
décarbonation de la route il faut la
faire bien
évidemment mais ce qu'on dit c'est qu'
attention petit à petit il faudra
prendre en compte toutes les
externalités positives ou négatives des
modes et il y en a un qui est
d'actualité c'est
l'énergie c'est pas que le CO2 l'énergie
le train pour une tonne transportée a
toujours six fois moins d'énergie que la
route quel que soit le type d'énergie
donc électrique pour électrique pourquoi
parce que le train ça glisse sur le rail
he le contact rail rou c'est tout petit
et la route ça frotte donc donc
l'énergie demain c'est la même chose que
le carbone donc l'énergie fossile il y
en aura moins l'énergie décarboné sera
rare et cher au démarrage c'est c'est
l'accès à cette énergie la consommation
d'énergie est importante si on prend
tous les autres facteurs euh la
saturation des routes et des autoroutes
donc la désaturation les accidents de la
route la santé euh finalement le CO2 en
valeur d'externalité évité ce n'est que
1/5è de tous les bénéfices qu'on a à
faire par la raille plutôt que par la
route en terme de coût d'externalité
évité voilà donc on a on a regardé le
CO2 c'est c'est une part importante he
des externalités évitées on se focus
là-dessus parce qu'il y a la question du
climat évidemment mais l'énergie la
désaturation des routes la pollution et
cetera ça compte tout autant voilà donc
moi je j'oriente plutôt vers regarder à
court terme avec des modes disponibles
la route qui peut être décarbonée parce
qu'on sur de la cour distance le rail
qui est décarboné intrinsè et qui en
plus a d'autres vertus euh de voir si on
peut aider les deux modes à mieux
travailler ensemble et inciter les
routiers français à à devenir
complémentaire complémentaire de du rail
euh oui alors moi j'ai j'ai juste mis
l'accent sur un point c'est c'est bon il
a une bonne nouvelle c'est que on parle
de 100 milliards d'euros pour le
ferroviaire bon pas encore financé mais
quand même là dans les 5 ans qui
viennent il y a on va voir une
augmentation de la régénération du
réseau c'est parti euh on a les r
métropolitains c'est nouveau on en
parlait pas quand on a discuté ici de la
loi climat et on a toujours l'objectif
du doublement du du frais de ferroviaire
donc c'est pas normal que réseau soit
pas encore prêt à répondre à la question
il il travaill par des plateformes
d'exploitation régionales où il
collectent l'ensemble des besoins de
flux effectivement qui vont circuler sur
le rail mais à un moment donné il va
falloir sortir du bois pour dire
attention tout ça n'est compatible que
si à tel endroit on fait des
investissements pour désaturer telle ou
telle infrastructure voilà et j'espère
que ané 2024 sera l'année où
l'architecte du réseau pourra
éclairer les choix qui sont nécessaires
pour éviter d'aller dans le mur c'estàd
que nous c'est pas la peine qu'on
investis dans des locomotives s'il y a
des endroits où on passe plus si on est
en France je passe plus bah très bien je
laisserai la place au Transilien mais je
vais pas investir pour développer le fra
ferrov donc on est un peu dans la
certitude là-dessus mais il faut laisser
les plateformes d'exploitation terminer
leur travail et ces plateformes
d'exploitation étant plutôt territorial
je vous rejoint en disant faut avoir une
vision d'axe je prends l'exemple de bah
si vous parlez de laquitain c'est
incroyable on a 3 % de part de marché
ferroviaire à la frontière côté andail
pour aller en Espagne 3 %. et vous voyez
les fil de camion considérable bah pour
faire ça il faut aménager en en axe euh
tout l'axe Atlantique ferroviaire on
sait qu'on a pas le gabaris qui va bien
on n pas les infrastructures qui va bien
est-ce que sur la période de
2028- 2032 on pourrait inscrire des
choses assez volontariste là-dessus
c'est considérable ce qu'on pourrait
récupérer sur le rail euh 3 % à comparer
à notre part de marché d'aujourd'hui 10
% moyen en France et 18 % en Europe en
voulant aller à 25 %
donc oui et je pense que cette question
des grands flux et des grands axes comme
l'artterre nord-est les sillons Laurin
sillon mzéland l'axe Atlantique doit
être regardé dans une logique d'axe
voilà pas uniquement par une logique
territoriale dans une vision
d'aménagement du territoire et de
programmation et ça rejoint ces
questions de désaturation et de
d'écoulement des trafics voilà je pense
à peu près avoir
répondu aux questions oui merci donc je
don don la parole au rapporteur Philipp
tabarou
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président vous avez répondu en partie
à à mes interrogations donc je vais
rebondir un petit peu sur ce que vous
avez dit donc on a bien pris la la
nouvelle enfin ou plutôt mal pris la
nouvelle du du report encore des
objectifs qu'on s'était fixé dans climat
et résilience de de de pouvoir doubler
la la part modale sur le sur le fra de
ferroviaire on a entendu que ça prendra
quelques années euh pour autant on était
plutôt comme vous optimiste après les
chiffres qu'on avait eu de l'année 2022
on les beaucoup moins depuis ce que vous
avez expliqué sur l'année 2023 à la fois
le choc énergétique les les les 90
millions de pertes au niveau des grèves
le problème de la Morienne et et le
problème qu'on qu'on évoquera sur
l'évolution du du paysage du du fret
dont quelque part vous êtes vous êtes
victime mais qui pourra permettre je
l'espère de de positiver un certain
nombre de choses moi je voulais vous
interroger
initialement sur l'état des des
infrastructures sur le niveau des péages
et sur l'évolution de ce paysage
concernant la l'état des infrastructures
vous vous l'avez dit on en avait parlé
ici même en juillet dernier avec le
président de de l'Alliance 4
4F voilà délivrer un outil industriel à
la hauteur des besoins des entreprises
ferroviaires c'était et des chargeur
c'est c'est
l'objectif je rappelle que dans cette
commission aussi nous avions alerté très
fortement sur les insuffisances du
dernier contrat de de de performance que
nous souhaitons voir bien sûr réviser
entre SNCF réseau et l'État et nous
avons notamment insisté sur le manque de
d'opérabilité des indicateurs qui sont
qui sont en envisager la véritable
adéquation entre les sillons attribués
et les besoins des clients et nous
quelque part vos vos remarques encore
pose un certain nombre de problèmes on
est pour la régénération on est à fond
pour la modernisation qui quasi
inexistante dans notre pays on a
l'impression d'être schizophrène à
chaque fois parce qu'on quand on dit il
faut régénérer moderniser le réseau et
notamment pour les voyageurs mais nous
aussi on pense au fret d'un autre côté
vous nous dites on est inquiet ça risque
de de couper enfin ou de de mettre à mal
notre évolution alors que voilà c'est
pas ce qu'on veut donc quelque part vous
parlez de ces plateformes d'exploitation
du du réseau euh c'est pas une surprise
que réseau aura dans les années à venir
des moyens supplémentaires pourer à bien
cette régénération et la compatibilité
bien sûr avec le développement du fra de
ferroviaire voilà doit être intégré et
et à chaque fois que cette question
revient et cette concurrence qu'on a
l'impression de vivre entre le transport
de voyageur et le transport de
marchandis nous pose un certain nombre
de problèmes le niveau de des péages euh
bon vous le vous le savez vous l'avez
rappelé les deux ministres le maire et
bonne ont confié enfin parce que c'est
un sujet là aussi dont on parle depuis
un certain nombre d'années euh dans dans
cette commission à l'Inspection générale
des finances et à l'inspection générale
de l'environnement le soin de réaliser
cette mission sur la tarification de de
l'usage et le financement du du du
réseau ferroviaire bon on a vu la lettre
de mission qui ont été adressé il y a
une comparaison à l'échelle européenne
des tarifications qui est demandé c'est
vrai que ce sont des éléments qui qui
qui reviennent régulièrement on a du mal
à comprendre pourquoi on a ce taux de
enfin ce ce coup des péag aussi
important dans notre pays ce qui ne
semble pas être le cas des autres pays
européens donc voilà on sait aussi qu'il
y a une étude ils nous l'ont fait passer
de de l'Agence française du du rail sur
la la grande vitesse et et et qui laisse
penser que une réduction des péages
infinés pourra bénéficier à notre
système ferroviaire en général la
question se pose bon je sais dans des
termes différents concernant le fret et
et voà j'esè j'espère que cette mission
pourra apporter des réponses vous d'ors
et déjà voilà sur quelle modalité
estimeriez-vous pertinente de voir les
les différents types de redevances
évoluer est-ce que cela vous semble une
bonne chose de remettre à PL le le
modèle économique du du fret ferroviaire
en prenant exemple sur d'autres pays
européens enfin le dernier point vous
l'avez esquissé mais mais je pense et je
sais que c'est un sujet de préoccupation
particulièrement important pour vous
c'est l'évolution du paysage du fret
ferroviaire vous l'avez dit euh SN Fret
SNCF connaîra dans un futur proche
d'importants
bouleversements qui à n'en pas douter
peuvent avoir des répercussions très
importantes sur le secteur quelles sont
pour vous les les modalités un petit peu
plus détaillées du plan de de
discontinuité qui sont d'ors et déjà
est-ce qu'elles sont d'ors déjà figées
et et et à l'inverse qu'est-ce qui qui
peut faire encore l'objet de de
discussion d'ajustement et et et de C
décisions et et je dirais qu'au-delà de
frit SNCF mais vous avez rappelé sa sa
place et et du groupe rle plus largement
comment voyez-vous et appréendez-vous
les évolutions sur le
secteur merci monsieur le rapporteur je
vous laisse répondre au rapporteur alors
concernant les péages bon euh moi on se
plain pas des péages euh ils sont euh il
doit pas être le le facteur déterminant
pour réseau de savoir comment ils
doivent développer le fret parce que
sinon par rapport au voyageur je veux
dire il f des TGV sur le réseau donc
donc le modèle économique de réseau doit
pas être uniquement orienté sur j'ajuste
les péages où je choisis mes trafic en
fonction des phag et donc là il doit y
avoir une une orientation claire sur ce
qu'on veut faire du réseau pour le frais
de ferroviaire parce que sinon le modèle
économique naturel autour des péages
incite pas à faire du fret hein dit
souvent qu'on paye pas le coût marginal
après on paye les péages un petit peu
plus chers que dans le reste de l'Europe
mais en même temps il y a dans le plan
de relance des aides supplémentaires qui
ont été donné pour les péages je je je
vais même vous dire je je pense que pas
mal des opérateurs de Fred seraient à
payer des payages un tout petit peu plus
chers même si ça va pas révolutionner
l'économie de réseau si on a la qualité
qui va avec parce que un un un sillon
qui est dans le marché et qui est
performant ça nous permet d'être
compétitif du point de vue économique le
sonillon c'est le transit time donc
c'est le temps de rotation des
locomotives des conducteurs si on gagne
3 heur sur un sillon je gagne je gagne
bien plus que le prix des péag qu'on
augmenta donc je suis prêt à partager
les gains de productivité avec réseau
dit autrement voilà ça va pas
révolutionner l'économie du frais dans
l'économie globale de réseau mais moi je
suis prêt à payer la qualité de service
notamment sur le transport combiné les
autoroutes ferroviaires j'ai et je me
suis déjà exprimé plusieurs fois
là-dessus il y a quelques anomalies
c'est quand on a des des des concurrents
qui roule avec des diesel sous catenire
alors que nous on fait l'électrique à 90
% et ensuite on fait les derniers
kilomètres uniquement en diesel quand
c'est pas électrifié il y a quand même
quelque chose qui ne colle pas c'estàd
qu' une infrastructure disponible en
électrique et et pour des raisons
d'économie hein de faire du bout en bout
pour pas changer de locomotive je fais
en diesel sous catener là il y a quelque
chose dans la concurrence ferroviaire
qui ne joue pas c'est handicap he pour
Fred de faire 90 % d'électrique jeis
obligé de changer de locomotive he donc
il y a un petit coup de changement de
locomotive mais je me demande si vous
pourriiez pas avoir une une adaptation
aussi des péages en fonction de quand
l'électrique est disponible si on vous
sou électrique c'est pas le même pH que
si on roule avec des diesel sous
caténner voilà pour assiter à utiliser
l'énergie positive ça c'est intérieur au
secteur frit de ferroviaire donc voilà
moi les pH je m'en plains pas je je je
pense même qu'on pourrait avoir sur le
coup là une incitation à la performance
des sillons donnés à fret par une
augmentation progressive de phéage si la
qualité est vraiment là et engageante
avec des contrats CADR comme ça a été
dit tout à l'heure alors fr SNF donc
quelques mots sur la
discontinuité c'est ce qui est ce qui
est violent pour pour les de
l'entreprise c'est d'être revenu à
l'équilibre comme j'ai dit de pas avoir
de plaignant et de se retrouver à devoir
payer la sanction du
passé la la discontinuité consiste en
quoi elle consiste à éviter de
rembourser 5 milliards et là c'est la
liquidation économique de frit donc le
point d'équilibre qui a été trouvé entre
l'État et la commission mais évidemment
on a contribué à essayer de de l'ajuster
c'est que contrairement à la
jurisprudence en la matière que nous
avait présenté la Commission européenne
c'est moin 50 % d'AC it 50 % de
personnel - 50 % d'actifs et un
changement d'actionnaire y compris
majoritaire bon là ça franchissait
toutes les liges rouge que j'ai cité
tout à
l'heure ce que la Commission a compris
c'est qu'en allant trop loin dans la
demande de réduction de la voilure de
fret SNCF c'est pas le rail qui allait
en profiter donc les concurrents
ferroviaires mais la route parce qu'il y
a une double concurrence et c'est pour
eux entre les deux donc il raisonne le
marché pertinent c'est le fr ferroviaire
non le marché pertinent c'est le
transport de marchandise
terrestre et c'est pas comme ça que ça
raisonne du point de vue du droit de la
concurrence c'est concurrent ferroviaire
contre concurrent ferroviaire sauf que
si on nous demande d'abandonner 50 % de
trafic de fret comme j'ai dit il y a un
million de camions de plus sur les
routes est-ce que c'est ce qu'on veut
est-ce que c'est compatible a le droit
de l'environnement et le traité de
l'Union d'ailleurs qui met
l'environnement très haut ils ont
compris et ça a retenu un peu le bras de
la commission il pouit pas appliquer le
scénario à l'Italia ou d'autres
scénarios où ils ont appliqué en
jurisprudence 50 % de de réduction de
voilure donc finalement on se retrouve à
préserver quand même 80 % de l'activité
frite en chi d'affaires
90 % des
emplois même si les 10 % bah il va
falloir c'est notre travail hein trouver
une une nouvelle activité d'enfette ou
dans la SNCF et on saura faire euh et
c'est difficile pour ces personnels là
parce que Clement çaetombe dessus c'est
pas on l'a pas perdu parce que le client
veut plus de nous il y a même des
clients qui disent on voudrait vous
garder mais bon la Commission a imposé
qu'on qu'on abandonne ces trafics alors
qu'est-ce qu'on abandonne on abandonne
des trafics on dit à moyen dédiés
c'estàdire c'est des trains complets
achetés par des clients réguliers
fréquents essentiellement à 95 % c'est
laattraction ferroviaire pour des
opérateurs de
combinés par contre on garde tout le
marché industriel voilà y a qu'un petit
il y a qu'un flux d'arcellor qui rentre
dans cette catégorie première et fret
SNCF donc tout le marché industriel
c'est quoi c'est la sidérurgie la chimie
les armées le nucléaire les produits de
grande consommation l'automobile les
ciments et cetera le BTP les céréales
l'agricult sûr pour non seulement le
vagon isolé mais aussi tous les trains
entiers irréguliers voilà pour lequel on
a installer en fait sur le territoire et
tout le territoire national une capacité
de production qu'on partage entre tous
les clients donc c'est la grosse
différence avec ce qu'on abandonne ce
qu'on abandonne c'est dédier un client
quand un trafic s'arrête on enlève les
locomotives on enlève les conducteurs
les moyens sont affectés un client ce
que nous gardons c'est il y a que Fred
qui fait ça à l'échelle du territoire
français c'est ce qu'on appelle la
gestion capacitaire une capacité de
transport mais on sait pas si la
locomotive un jour le travail pour le
client a ou pour le client B grâce à
cette mutualisation des moyens on est
capable d'offrir des faibles fréquences
des fréquences variables pardon des
faibles volumes et donc des gens qui
n'avaient pas accès au ferroviair pour
des petits volumes ou des fréquences
extrêmement variables de train viennent
chez nous pour parce qu'on peut l'offrir
euh quelqu'un qui fait des trains
réguliers il aura du mal à se
positionner comme ça donc finalement la
leçon artinée de l'histoire c'est que il
y a quand même besoin même si la
concurrence est ouverte hein même si
fret et la nouvelle société qui va en
être sera dans la concurrence
ferroviaire Marie DRAC m'a dit oui vous
êtes un peu l'opérateur
systémique dont chaque pays a besoin
pour offrir ce service tout territoire
parce qu'on couvre tous les territoires
on a une couverture territoiale très
importante toute taille de l'eau nombre
de wagons et toute fréquence
voilà et donc donc on on gardera ça à
partir du 1er janvier 2025 ça représente
80 % du chif d'affair je pense que ça a
rassuré les industriels hein parce que
certains se disaient mais qu'il ferait
disparaît est-ce que on doit passer à la
route s'organise logistiquement voilà
donc on a trouvé un point d'équilibre
qui aujourd'hui permet de dire que ça
remet pas en
cause la la la la la croissance du
ferroviaire et puisque nous allons
perdre bah c'est des trafics que par
nature les concurrents sa faire donc le
premier bilan c'est qu'au 1er janvier
2024 on doit abordonner 13 flux on
Abanda encore une dizaine au 1er juillet
2024 sur ces trafics régulier fréquents
et pour le prier janvier 2024 je n'ai
pas d'alerte comme quoi il y a personne
qui reprendrait en ferroviaire donc il y
a pas de transfert modal donc on a pas
d'alerte pour le 1er janvier on verra
pour le 1er juillet en plus comme la
conjoncture est plutôt pas favorable on
a des concurrents qui ont des
locomotives et des moyens disponible
donc il n demande même pas de les aider
ils sont capables de reprendre les
trafics
voilà merci je vais donner la parole à
Jacques
fernck merci monsieur le Président oui
effectivement toute la question c'est de
de savoir si la nature d'opérateur
historique et donc le potentiel que ça
représente permettra au bras de
repousser voilà le fameux bras dont Fred
SNCF est amputé euh plus plus
globalement sur donc on on a vu donc ça
a bougé d'un point et demi euh le report
modal ce qui est quand même euh je
historiquement euh ça s'est pas vu
depuis longtemps et donc si
contrairement à à tous les plans frais
précédent historiquement ont réussi
effectivement alors peut-être pas
l'échéance 2030 mais dans ces eau-l à à
doubler la part modale du frite
ferroviaire et qu'en même temps les
objectifs fixés au niveau européen du
fret ferroviaire sont
atteints nous aurions donc quand même un
différentiel très important entre l'état
du fret ferroviaire français et
globalement le fret ferroviaire européen
différentiel à notre détriment je crois
d'une au moins d'une dizaine de points
hein autant dire que si on échoue à
doubler la part modale de notre fra
ferroviaire euh on serait clairement
déconnecté de l'Europe ferroviaire hein
on a déjà des signaux vous y avez fait
allusion qui sont inquiétant de ce point
de vuelà donc il y a des leviers qu'il
faut clairement actionner franchement
pour éviter un tel scénario donc vous y
avez déjà fait allusion toujours un peu
compliqué d'intervenir après beaucoup de
questions
euh donc on a compris que c'est c'est du
côté des des écarts de compétitivité à
compenser entre le ferroviaire et le
routier routier qui ne P guerre ses
externalités donc on on n pas comme les
Allemands de de lkv mot même si ça peut
peut-être bouger de ce point de vu là du
côté de l'Alsace vers 2025 peut-être du
Grand T à l'horizon
202728 alors vous avez fait allusion à à
l'idée de de de crédit d'impôt liés aux
external évité par les transporteurs qui
feraient le choix de jouer le report
modal
donc en gros bon une question auquelle
vous avez déjà largement apporté en
partie réponse donc la question de
savoir comment rectifier de façon
structurante et durable cet avantage
contreproductif du frê routier comment
inciter celui-ci à s'inscrire comme vous
le disiez dans une complémentarité avec
le
rail merci je vais à Pierrejean
Rochette merci merci
président monsieur le Président bon on
voit que dans le pays du TGV on a on a
négligé le le frit et c'est
malheureusement
aujourd'hui un petit peu les
conséquences aussi de tout cela que que
nous payons j'ai une question concernant
la concurrence que vous évoquiez entre
la route et leorail vous évoquez
notamment le prix des poids lourds
électriques à venir
avez-vous pris en compte dans votre
analyse le fait que bien
entendu les transporteurs routiers
nutiliseront plus le pétrole versus
l'électricité ça c'est une évidence mais
surtout que le coût de l'amortissement
va être étalé sur des durées beaucoup
plus longues qu'un véhicule thermique
parce que je pense que malgré le coût
d'investissement de ces
véhicule le prix au kilomètre de la
route ne va pas
s'envoler entretien va s'effondrer et la
durée d'amortissement va être plus que
doublée donc là-dessus sur les éléments
que vous évoqué tout à l'heure j'ai une
petite enfin j'ai une petite incertitude
je suis pas convaincu véritablement que
le prix du routier soit aussi dissuasif
que ça sur les lignes que vous
abandonnez juste une question sont-elles
regroupées sur le même secteur
géographique
ou sont-elles dispersées sur tout le
territoire national et puis euh
au profit de qui se fait ce
désengagement c'estàd parlons-nous
d'opérateurs locaux français ou
d'opérateur étranger et puis dernière
question pensez-vous que l'accès au
marché de cette profession de
transporteurs routiers ferroviaire est
suffisamment aujourd'hui ouvert
suffisamment souple pour susciter de
nouvelles vocations notamment pour des
transporteurs routiers qui voudraent
aller vers la multimodalité en propre et
aussi pour les chargeurs privé qui
voudrai finalement faire pour leur
propre compte et ça c'est pas une
question mais juste un un complément je
vous rejoins sur le fait qu'il faut
fiscalement que les chargeurs trouvent
un intérêt aller vers le multimodal ça
passera soit par le sujet de la TVA soit
par un allègement on doit aller vers ça
pour que ça fonctionne merci merci je
vais donner la parole à Pierre bar
oui merci monsieur le
Président TR TR sujets sur la j'ai bien
compris is ça fait longtemps qu'on a
compris que la disponibilité des sillons
est un vrai sujet et si il permettra
l'isibilité et la mise en place d'une
planification et de réellement
travailler très efficacement sur la sur
un retour au Fred sur les rails la
complexité qui est aussi enfin moi je
rappelle d'une histoire parce que je
suis autour de roiss euh il y a eu un un
projet qui s'appelait
orocarex qui était un serpent de mer
pendant quelques années et puis c'est
interrompu depuis plusieurs années
maintenant et la problématique c'était
les accords internationaux qui faisaient
que bon bah il y avait un boulot qui
était fait du côté français et ça n'a
pas pris suffisamment côté allemand côté
belge de façon à trouver quelque chose
qui permettait de raccorder par un enfin
c'est du frais ferroviaire très grande
vitesse et de raccorder comme ça un
aéroport international avec une zone de
desserte qui soit qui soit adapté donc à
un moment donné il y a il y a les
sillons à l'intérieur de de au niveau
national et après ça comment ça se
raccorde sur les territoires voisins de
façon à ce qu'à un moment donné ça ça
aboutisse de l'autre côté de la
frontière mais sur un réseau qui existe
aussi qui soit performant et qu'on
puisse avoir une une cohérence de sillon
à l'international et juste pour enfin ce
que VO quel collègue est important c'est
la la question du aujourd'hui les zones
d'activité la la le le les camions sont
sont sont les gens sur sur les les
autoroutes enfin moi je connais bien
l'autoroute à 1 qui qui raccorde Paris à
Lille qui est un mur des camions he on a
partout ce même phénomène en en France
sur plein d'autoroute et on voit bien
que la route elle a elle amène
directement sur les zones d'activité
c'est vra que est- qui est pas le cas
pour le réseau Férré et c'est faut pas
s'étonner pourquoi du coup il y a des
camions sont privilégiés sur les sur les
transports et sur ces zones d'activité
et moi j'ai autour de chez moi des
anciennes zones d'activité qui datent
d'une cinquantaine d'années qui ell
était raccordé au faer qui elle était
parfaitement équipé ou euh les euh les
wagons le fret arrivait directement dans
les entrepôts était déchargé et après ça
il y avait un travail d'intermobilité
qui était de dessertes locales par des
véhicules routiers donc moi ma mon
interrogation c'est comment on peut être
acteur et actif sur quand on crée une
zone d'activité comment on équipe les
zones d'activités existantes euh par le
faire de façon à demander à ce que le
faer aille dans les zones de logistique
et à partir de là on on créa les
conditions pour que à la base euh le
fret arrive sur du fer et non sur des
euh sur des
camions si je vais donner la parole à
Simon
ha merci monsieur le Président euh
monsieur le Président moi je souhaitais
évoquer euh en écho à ce que vous avez
déjà pu dire mais quelques sujets
davantage breton euh pour le coup euh le
volet mobilité du CP a été voté il y a
dans ce volet mobilité un un point
important consacré au développement du
fret ferroviaire vous connaissez la
situation péninsulaire de de notre
région l'un des grands enjeux et je vous
rejoins complètement ainsi que les
collègues notamment philippe Tabarot sur
le besoin de régénération réhabilitation
en particulier des voies ferrées eu sur
les ports eu qu'il s'agisse de de Brest
ou de l'Orient la desserte de de nos
interlandantes portuaires de la même
façon sur les les lignes capillaires de
fret là un investissement partagé par
l'État et et par la région nous avons
également des industries
agroalimentaires qui ont des besoins
très importants donc là c'est à la fois
les voix et puis tout ce que les
collègues on ont pu dire sur les
incitations pour ces entreprises à à
recourir davantage au fret et puis le
deuxième sujet sur le le développement
du transport combiné vous avez évoqué
qui est les chiffres au niveau national
mais pour la Bretagne c'est 1 % donc on
voit bien les marges de progression sont
quand même extrêmement extrêmement élevé
à la fois au sein de la région et de la
région vers les autres
territoires encore une fois en
particulier sur les les différents
secteurs industriels donc là il y a des
besoins qui ont été identifi est-ce que
vous pourriez nous confirmer les les
actions que vous envisagez de de
conduire pour faire en sorte que la
dynamique soit au rendez-vous sur ce
sujet je vous
remercie monsieur le Président je vous
donne la parole
euh alors sur sur la question de la la
route et de son coût euh bon c'est j'ai
noté que c'est trois fois le prix d'un
tracteur diesel aujourd'hui le coût d'un
tracteur électrique donc même si on
double amortissement enfin TR TR c'est
énorme alors ça va baisser peut-être au
fil du temps mais c'est surtout le temps
de déploiement temps de déploiement
parce que ça nécessite des
infrastructures ça va rajouter de la
contrainte logistique au routier parce
qu'ils devont avoir des rendez-vous pour
recharger que ce soit de l'hydrogène ou
de
l'électrique donc ça c'est vraiment un
bouleversement logistique qui va arriver
alors peut-être qu'en France on est
capable de le faire vite hein je je je
ne sais pas mais n'oubliez pas que
l'essentiel des du développement du
transport routier en France dans les 30
dernières années c'est fait au profit du
pavillon étranger de transit est-ce
qu'on est sûr que les pays voisins vont
aller au même rythme moi je je suis pas
certain est-ce que tout ça va être voilà
chacun va financer son déploiement de de
flotte et de de de système faut déjà
mettre toute l'Europe d'accord donc très
sincèrement ça va prendre des décennies
ça va être ça va être long c'est pas
c'est pas une affaire de 10 à 20 ans
donc le seul message là-dessus c'est
nous sommes tout de suite disponibles il
y a des solutions routières
complémentaires du rail qui sont déjà
décarboné et donc effectivement le
transport combiné est une solution sans
doute celle qui va donner des résultats
le plus rapide voilà le plus rapide donc
et on a des routiers qui s'y intéressent
le groupe Charles André est opérateur de
transport combiné la société bretonne
lae développe du transport combiné on
vient lancer un Ren Lille avec eux donc
et et et par contre leur crainte c'est
d'aller à Lyon parce qu'ils savent pas
si on va pouvoir rajouter des
allers-retours à cause du passage en
Île-de-France problème de réseau donc
donc le développement du transport gbiné
il va être beaucoup dépendant de la
disponibilité des capacit
d'infrastructure bon pour la Bretagne il
a une plateforme à Renn qui est bien
placée peut-être faudra un jour
envisager un autre emplacement mais
clairement c'est une terre de combiné la
Bretagne avec l'agroalimentaire avec ça
peut être complété par des produits de
grande consommation donc ce qui compte
c'est que il y a pas une multiplication
non plus des plateformes parce que
disons les choses par le passé il y a eu
des erreurs commises on en faisait une
dans chaque département voire deux par
département parfois donc se fais des
concurrences faut massifier le transport
combiné ça a besoin de massification
donc si on en fait une à Laval et en
même temps on en fait une à reen il y a
un problème voilà je je suis un peu
direct mais je pense qu'il faut un
moment donné faire un choix faut même se
concerter entre régions pour dire où
est-ce que où est-ce qu'on investit et
donc ce réseau de plateforme combiné
nous avec le gntc on a fait des
propositions pour dire où on voit dans
les 5 à 10 ans les développements de
plateformes nouvelles les extensions des
plateformes existantes parce qu'il faut
les agrandir et donc les tubes de train
combinés qui qui qui qui les reléront
voà et donc c'est là qu'on a besoin des
infrastructures dans le cas des contrats
de plan état région première vague puis
la deuxième qui suivra celui qui va être
mise en
place maintenant mais avec une vision
Nationale d'Architecture nationale de
ces flux euh qui sont parfaitement
connus de la DGITM euh sur les le
désengagement qui va à qui de notre de
nos flux à cause de la discontinuité
est-ce qu'il y aura de nouveaux
opérateurs quels sont les opérateurs ben
à 95 % sont des opérateurs existants
euh donc doutge band cargo
linéas région Raay peut-être un peu
Europorte euh il y a j'ai entendu parler
de l'arrivée potentielle d'un nouvel
opérateur en France qui s'appelle Medway
qui qui est une filiale de MSC qui
investit beaucoup dans le ferroviaire
sur l'ensemble de l'Europe ils ont pas
encore leur certificat de sécurité il
est possible qu'ils reprennent un des 23
flux voilà mais mais ça ce serait la
seule exception à l'arrivée d'un nouvel
entrant alors que c'est plutôt les
opérateurs existant qui reprennent ce
que nous avonsedans
euh donc à la fois des étrangers et des
Français là-dedans voilà pour répondre à
votre
question sur euh
oui alors
eurocarex bon le problème oui il y a
d'abord la question des sons
internationaux donc il y a une directive
européenne qui vient de sortir sur la
partage de la capacité au niveau
européen et qui va faciliter enfin
forcer un peu plus la coordination entre
gérant d'infrastructure européens les
autorités de régulation nationale sont
chargé de veiller à ce que par exemple
les travaux soient bien coordonnés d'un
pays à l'autre parce que c'est bien de
bien faire le travail en France mais si
quand on passe la frontière on se
retrouve à faire le zigzag dans des
travaux en Allemagne ça va pas
satisfaire nos chargeurs donc donc ça
progresse au niveau européen au niveau
réglementaire de ce point de vue-l après
je pense qu'il y a un certain nombre de
trafic de frit qui peuvent aussi relever
d'une logique aménagement du territoire
alors je sais pas si eurocarex avec la
grande vitesse trouve son équilibre
économique mais je le train des primeurs
le fameux train des primeurs qui est le
train moi je dis c'est l'Orient Express
du FR ferroviaire parce qu'il est connu
maintenant presque dans toute l'Europe
très célèbre voilà par sa
publicité tout le monde est attaché bon
ce train c'est un train d'aménagement du
territoire il trouve pas son équilibre
économique tout seul il a une valeur
environnementale mais il a aussi une
valeur parce qu'il relie le marché de
Perpignan avec le mine de ringis ça ça a
de la valeur parce que ça évite de
déplacer des emplois en Espagne pour
faire la préparation
des marchandises qui arrivent qui
arrivent à rangis donc est-ce qu'il peut
y avoir des trains d'aménagement du
territoire comme il y a des trains
Intercités ou des TER qui font l'objet
d'une d'une DSP moi je pense que oui
mais ça s'applique à des trains
réguliers fréquents dont on trouve pas
l'équilibre économique naturel et parce
qu'il y a des avantages industriels il y
a des avantages d'emploi dans les
territoires et il y a des avantages
environnementaux voilà eurocarex je
crois n'avait pas trouvé complètement
son modèle économique des gens qui
étaient prêt à investir après s'il y a
il y a un intérêt d'aménagement du
territoire en l'occurrence européen pour
relier des des aéroports entre eux ou
des zones de consommation entre elles ça
peut être intéressant et le train le
train des primeurs s prête bien c'est un
train régulier fréquent voilà la
commission d'ailleurs est favorable au
aux délégations de service publics c'est
plutôt les États-membres qui sont
frileux et le domaine d'application pour
moi c'est c'est des plans de transport
installés qui sont stables réguliers
comme du voyageur mais qui trouvent pas
leur modèle économique mais dont la
puissance publique se dit tiens là il y
a un intérêt euh qui dépasse simplement
le transport mais qui développe
l'économie zone d'activité embranchée
oui alors ça fait partie dans la note
que qu'on vous transmettra qu'on a remis
au Parlement des propositions les
nouveaux sites industriels ou
logistiques doivent évidemment être
pensés en priorité avec une une
recherche de solutions permettant
d'avoir un raccordement au rail
euh et puis sur les sur les existants
ben il faut aller redonner l'envie de de
redémarrer l'ouverture de ces
embranchements alors il y a quelque
chose qui est méconnu et donc ça fait
aussi c'est partie de nos propositions
c'est que dans le plan de relance il a
aussi été prévu 15 % de CEE certificat
d'économie d'énergie pour les chargeurs
donc c'est les chargeurs qui on
bénéficié 15 % d'économie sur des
trafics ferroviaires qui correspondrait
à du report modal donc je suis chargeur
je fais de la route demain je bascule ce
flux route sur rail j'ai une économie de
15 % c'est pas négligeable hein c'est
pas négligeable des fois ils hésitent
pour 5 % de prix donc 15 % c'est pas
négligeable il y a un seul inconvénient
que je vous livre c'est que pour
l'instant ça s'applique au flux existant
alors donc on a posé la question mais
pourquoi ça s'applique pas à des
développements donc à des nouveaux
trafique je lance un nouveau flux j'ai
le choix entre la route et le rail
pourquoi je bénéficie pas de 15 %
d'avantage si je fais du rail plutôt que
de la route et puis les commissionnaires
de transport qui sont des intermédiaires
qui utilise pas mal de petits chargeurs
qui savent pas acheter le ferroviaire
directement pas non plus donc voilà je
pense qu'on pourrait élargir la mesure
qui est bonne parce qu'elle s'adresse
pas aux opérateurs l'occurrence mais
mais au chargeurs au clients finaux pour
les inciter à utiliser plus le rail et
du coup ils auraient envie peut-être de
réactiver un it ou de remettre en
service des embranchements existant
euh voilà et sur sur le plan de relance
benah sur les capillaires
l'interland les embranchements il y a il
y a il y a des enveloppes qui sont
prévues hein au niveau état faut juste
gérer les priorités territoire par
territoire et sur les discussions qui
auront lieu dans chaque région pour voir
ce que ce que chaque région considère
comme prioritaire avec SNCF réseau et
avec les opérateurs de fret comme comme
étant les it et les capillaires qu'on
peut améliorer ou
développer merci je vais donner la
parole à Nicole bonnefo
oui monsieur le Président moi je je je
suis sénatrice du département de la
charante et donc quand j'entends parler
de camions euh et des camions transit en
particulier je sais ce que ça représente
puisque c'est énorme le trafic qui euh
par la nationale 10 rejoint la métropole
bordelaise et et l'Espagne dans les deux
sens via la nationale 10 il y a
également la nationale 141 qui est la
trans le qui vient du centre de la
France et qui elle
aussi amène des flux immenses de de de
de camions transit donc bien évidemment
on préférait que ces marchandises
aillent sur le rail que sur la route euh
en attendant qu'ils aillent sur le rail
parce que je sais pas si si un jour ça
va arriver euh on aimerait bien qu'ils
aillent sur l'autoroute quand il y a des
autoroutes à proximité et ils sont même
pas capables de cela puisque évidemment
l'autoroute est payante donc c'est mieux
de prendre les Nationales quand elles
sont maintenant en plus à deux fois de
voix ce qui représente des autoroutes
gratuites euh donc le problème est
entier et et donc j'en témoigne ici euh
et je témoigne également de la garde de
fret puisque j'ai dans mon département à
Cognac pour pas le citer une garde de
frette neuve qui a été une duré en 2007
et qui était faite pour justement
transporter bah le cognac des millions
de bouteilles de Cognac et éviter
qu'elles aillent sur la route moralité
on a la gare de fret neuve qui ne
fonctionne pas et les millions de
bouteilles de Cognac qui partent par la
route et donc et évidemment les élus
locaux demandent soit le fret soit la
route avec des mises à deux fois de voix
pour que les camions circulent mie voyez
donc on marche sur la tête donc je suis
là pour témoigner je je j'ose dire que
je m'épuise depuis des années à essayer
de de de de résoudre ces problèmes de le
faire
comprendre et les réponses ne sont pas
apportées je ne comprends pas pourquoi
quand on a une guerre frite on ne met on
puisse pas mettre les les la marchandise
sur sur ces rails là pourquoi voilà
c'est mon
témoignage merci je partage le point de
vue sur sur les nationales et
l'autoroute euh j'ai la 83 et donc je
vais donner la parole à Guillaume chev
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président sénateur de la Mayenne vous
avez parlé de l'aval j'avais pas prévu
forcément d'invenir vous avez déjà
répondu à beaucoup de questions sur les
enjeux de la
régénération du réseau et et son
importance et auquel je je souscris vous
le savez dans dans mon département il y
a des travaux actuellement de
régénération sur la voie qui est conduit
à la plateforme combinée de de
châteaugontier sur Mayenne et
effectivement il y a toujours un projet
qui est à l'étude sur la zone de de
saint-bertevin en au bord de de la LGV
donc un positionnement stratégique tout
à fait intéressant donc j'aimerais que
vous approfondissiez un petit peu votre
réflexion puisque vous avez indiqué en
répondant à notre collègue breton que
voilà il fallait une coordination avec
la Bretagne entre Rennes et Laval parce
que ce projet sur un site de 25 hactares
est à l'étude depuis un certain nombre
d'années il représente un investissement
financier important donc euh il faut que
il soit ajusté et et et pertinent donc
merci de de nous
éclairer merci chers collègues je vais
donner la parole à Pierrel
Devinaz merci monsieur le Président
écoutez monsieur le Président je suis
moi sénateur du nouveau rô et la
métropole de Lyon et en ce qui concerne
les poids lourds sur nos autoroutes on
on est bien servi et et je vais
prolonger ce qu'a dit
Nicole bonne foi quand ils utilisent les
national je dirais c'est un moindre mal
mais moi je constate qu'aujourd'hui ça
circule de partout sur des routes
départementales qui ne sont qui sont à
la charge des collectivités
territoriales et à ma connaissance les
les l'argent ou ce qu'on qu'on perçoit
de la route ne retombe pas sur les
collectivités territoriales et ça finira
par poser et ça pose un problème et je
pense que les élus locaux vont réagir
par rapport à cela tout à l'heure j'ai
entendu qu'il y avait des des accords
pour coordonner les travaux
entre au niveau de l'Europe entre les
pays alors je vais comme j'ai un nom
savoyard qui a un million de poids
lourds par an qui passe dans les vallées
de savoir il est évident que les
Savoyards seraient assez satisfaits que
tous ces poids lourds basculent sur le
rail et donc j'en viens à cette
meilleure coordination est-ce que vous
avez des éléments vous par rapport à
Lyon Turin et la meilleure coordination
d'accès entre côté italien côté français
et la logique qui est en train de se
développer de rénover l'ancienne ligne
qui fait Modane
Dijon merci je vous propose de répondre
à Nicole Bonnefois parce qu'elle a
rendez-vous médical et peut-être pas
pvoir écouter la réponse jusqu'au bout
oui
alors c'est vrai qu'il il y a eu des
investissements faits dans le fret
Cognac en tête les garbis il y a un plan
gar bois à une certaine époque le
problème c'est qu'à la fin c'est le
chargeur qui décide malheureusement
c'est ni nous en tant que transporteur
ni nous ni les ni les politiques qu'on
investi donc et c'est les chargeurs qui
choisissent en fonction du rapport qu
aité prix tout simplement par contre on
pourrait peut-être regarder sur des
territoires comme ça la mise en place de
navettes de façon à massifier alors j'en
rejoin ça rejoint aussi ce que je veux
dire sur les plateformes multimodales
c'est le fret économiquement pertinent
dès lors qui massifie dès qu'on le
disperse dès qu'on fait des petits petit
volume donc il faudrait peut-être avoir
des choses qui ramènent sur Bordeaux et
qui permettent de massifier pour ensuite
renvoyer dans des dans des flux beaucoup
plus importants c'est la même chose pour
l'aval si on multiplie les endroits de
de d'échange entre la route et le rail
ça veut dire qu'on a deux portiques on a
deux systèmes qui cohabitent à peu de
distance et on massifie pas les trains
parce que le but c'est de les remplir à
100 % voilà un train qui est rempli à 60
% il trouve pas son équilibre économique
on narrive pas à développer donc le
risque c'est c'est ça parle souvent de
bonnes intentions he c'est chaque
territoire envie de montrer ce qu'il
fait pour pour le frais de ferroviaire
mais il faut le regarder au cas par cas
mais souvent l'intérêt collectif c'est
de massifier et de pas avoir trop
d'usine entre guillemets on fabrique des
trains pour avoir des de l'efficacité
économique sur le transfert à route et
puis de l'efficacité économique par le
remplissage des trains voilà donc donc
si la gare de de Cognac peut peut
générer des flux vers vers Bordeaux
qu'on massifie pour les envoyer ailleurs
c'est comme ça peut-être qu'il matière à
trouver hein je je je raisonne tout haut
et puis entre la Val et reen il faut
s'assurer que on va pas démassifier en
faant cela au point de de rendre le fret
un peu moins compétitif par rapport à la
route parce qu'à la fin ce sera
globalement perdant hein si le prix que
payent les chargeurs n'est pas
acceptable ils viendront pas voilà je
j'ai pas je peux pas répondre
précisément à Cognac mais je vous donne
le principe ou non je je je je
connaissais la réponse ceci dit massifié
on n arrive pas la preuve et la garde de
fret elle est fantôme abandonn
avec des investissements énormes de
l'État quand même et c'est pas
normal regarder au cas particulier après
il y a des régions qui qui regardent
aussi la possibilité d'avoir des
produits régionaux de collecte et de
ramassage qui ramèneent vers un H
national
euh j'ai eu un échange avec l'occcitan
ils veulent par exemple développer une
navette entre landendor et un hub par
exemple Toulouse qui permettrait ensuite
d'envoyer plus loin et de d'enlever des
camions sur l'endor bon c'est pas
interdit aussi qu'il ait s'il y a pas le
modèle économique qui va bien non
seulement un plan national mais aussi un
plan régional on pourrait dire
de de de de de ramassage et de collecte
et distribution qui soutient parce qu'il
y a des intérêts économiques et des
intérêts environnementaux reconnus
territorialement un produit navette
local qui amène à un hub et qui ensuite
permet d'aller beaucoup plus loin voilà
y a des solutions quand on trouve pas le
modèle économique commercialement nous
avec les clients bah c'est que leorail
n'est pas suffisamment compétitif pour
pour amener ses ces ces flux sur des
trafics nationaux c'est une piste mais
qui doit être regardé au cas par cas
ensuite sur les vallées de Savoie moi je
suis évidemment pour le Lyon tururin
c'est des projets de très très très très
très très long terme évidemment qu'il
faut le faire faut voir loin
euh par contre faut pas louper les accès
et ça a failli être le cas je ve dire ça
failli être le cas c'est qu'on a risonné
longurin mais on a pas on n pas pensé
que cl sur un pour le Fred ça commence à
Lyon en fait hein donc donc tous les
endroits où on doit de s'organiser par
des voies de service pour faire les
échanges de locomotive et cetera n'avait
pas été pensé dans le système on a dit
un grand tube puis ça suffit non pas
réalis voilà et donc donc les accès et
et les plateformes qui permettent
d'exploiter efficacement le fret de
l'Italie vers la France vont au-delà du
tu de lonura il faut un certain
d'investissements sur des voies de
service et qui ont la bonne longueur qui
permet de le faire ça a été pris hein
puisque le comité interministériel a
bien entendu le message et et maintenant
c'est pris en compte et les études vont
avoir lieu pour être sûr que le système
globalement est cohérent voilà mais Lyon
Turin ça va bien au-delà de du tube
lui-même ça ça remonte jusqu'à Lyon et
presque jusqu'à Turin il y a des
investissements à faire sur les lignes
existant merci je vais donner la parole
à Cédric chevaller
oui merci monsieur le Président
simplement je voudrais rebondir sur le
sur l'exemple que vient de donner notre
collègue Nicole Bonnefois sur sur la la
Gard de Cognac je suis assez surpris euh
parce que quand lorsqu'on fait un
investissement quel qu'il soit euh on en
mesure en tout cas la pertinence et si
je prenais un terme entrepreneurial on
ferait un une étude de marché
euh parce que avant de construire
quelque chose et notamment avec des
investissements je pense que ma collègue
me dirait que ça a coûté extrêmement
cher euh je suis assez surpris qu'à un
moment donné l'exemple qui est donné qui
est une forme de gabg euh financière euh
ne soit pas anticipé alors ma question
j'ai bien compris sur la notion de
compétitivité parce que ce qui fera que
on sortira de la route pour aller vers
le rail c'est qu'au final effectivement
le coût soit compétitif le coût il est
compétitif au travers euh euh d'un
certain nombre de de de frais structures
qui sont moins chères euh également euh
euh finalement que le le chargeur le
client final euh s'y retrouve et c'est
dans une logique de masse je suis
d'accord avec vous que on arrive à faire
des économies d'échelle mais moi
finalement au travers de des exemples et
de ce que vous me dites c'est quels sont
finalement les outils pour accompagner
les acteurs locaux pour amener justement
dans les études de marché et demain de
l'implantation d'infrastructure pour
dire que cette infrastructure soit au
moins équilibrée et permettre justement
dans cette stratégie plus large d'amener
le camion vers le rail je vous
remercie monsieur le président
ben je suis tout à fait d'accord he
c'est c'est faut raisonner en
partenariat public privé comme dans le
privé quand je fais un investissement je
m'assure qu'il y a un retour sur
investissement donc je sais pas si ça
avait été fait sur cognac peut-être mais
à la fin c'est pas la gare qui fait le
trafic voilà c'est comme ça qu'il faut
je le dis c'est pas la gare qui fait le
trafic c'est le fait que les chargeurs
et les utilisateurs de cette gare ont
envie de payer le prix du rail pour le
faire donc il faut il y il y a plein de
bureaux d'études hein qui existent en
France qui sont capables de faire cette
étude de marché et c'est un prê able
très sain que soit de l'argent public ou
de l'argent privé ou de l'argent public
privé d'avoir une analyse de marché
après c'est pas une assurance t risque
parce que à la fin pour que les contrats
commerciaux finissent par être signés
mais partir en aveugle en disant c'est
la poule et l'œuf je je fais une
infrastructure et puis le marché va
venir non ça des fois on fait des
erreurs voilà donc j'ai aucune idée
c'est peut-être pas le cas de Cognac
mais vous avez tout à fait raison il
faut éclairer les choix qui soient
public privé d'investissement par il y
a-t-il un marché qui permet de
rentabiliser
l'investissement bien s'il n'y a plus de
questions je vais remercier Frédéric
delomme pour pour son éclairage et et
ses interventions effectivement le le
fret ferroviaire est quelque chose de de
particulièrement important alors
essayons à l'AUE de l'année 2024 de
revenir sur 2022 et puis que ce soit
effectivement un trajet ou une ligne de
rail positive pour doubler un notre fête
ferroviaire merci de vos interventions
merci